ooh caius he's a tricky one you need to  pay close attention to the modes he uses  when he's in Ravager mode throw fire ice  lightning and wind at him when he  switches to commando lambaste him with  your melee weapon but here's the thing  you can't just rely on one type of magic  because if you stagger him with one type  you'll gain a resistance to it Caius  will throw a number of attacks at you  but many of them charge up in the air  before blasting you the split-second  timing required can be grueling if you  get caught up in a series of them it's  curtains you're so eager to die  here  [Music]  life is a journey you cannot stop me  okay let's do this  my children doesn't end here  [Music]